bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors dire que le retrait
américain peut permettre un retour des
talibans au pouvoir ses actes et que
leur présence sur le sol afghan a été
bénéfique est ce que selon vous c'est le
cas écoutez ça fait quand même vingt ans
que les américains sont présents
militairement en afghanistan et pour
quel résultat
c'est pas le statu quo parce que
beaucoup de choses se sont passées en 20
ans mais enfin on voit bien si vous
voulez que ce pays n'a jamais retrouvé
unités la stabilité à laquelle il aspire
et laquelle auquel aspirent les
populations bien entendu dont
l'occupation militaire étrangère
prolongés décidés unilatéralement par
les américains et leurs alliés au
lendemain on s'en souvient des attentats
du 11 septembre 2009 tout ça n'a révélé
aucun des problèmes qui frappent ce pays
et qui tue et qui concerne ces pays donc
le constat qu'on peut faire aujourd'hui
c'est évidemment celui d'un échec total
de cette longue occupation militaire
et puis deuxièmement une constat de
l'absence de perspectives parce
qu'effectivement dire qu'on se retire du
pays après l'avoir occupé pendant 20 ans
ça veut dire quoi que c'est à dire qu'en
réalité on a on n'a rien à proposer
alors justement parlant de propositions
à sera fera ni à proposer aux talibans
de participer à un gouvernement
intérimaire en attendant les élections
ça a pas l'air de les intéresser
quelques le président afghan s'ils
voulaient se rend nous principe de
réalité c'est-à-dire prennent en compte
l'existence de cette force politique et
militaire que représentait talibans
quoique l'on pense par ailleurs c'est
assez normal je suppose que le chef de
l'état afghan c'est de nous est une
sorte de négociation en plus ou moins
ouvertes avec l'ensemble des parties
concernées pour au moins réduire le
niveau si vous voulez des affrontements
mais on voit bien que il est si vous
voulez isolé dans cette démarche si les
puissances étrangères qui ont cru bon en
occuper ce pays en viennent à la
conclusion qu'il faut quitter parce que
toute façon à ne plus rien y faire les
enfants vont devoir régler leurs
problèmes entre eux ce qu'ils auraient
dû faire dès le départ finalement je
pense que
c'est l'intervention militaire
occidentale pour simplifier les ricaines
en particulier dans les différents pays
du moyen-orient aboutit toujours d'un
résultat c'est que on vient on sème le
chaos qu on repart c'est tout dire c'est
toujours le même scénario
une fois de plus l'occupation militaire
occidentale dans un pays du moyen-orient
n'aura servi à rien sinon à très souvent
à prolonger les souffrances des
populations
en tout cas ce rappeur à nenê parti aux
états unis pour rencontrer joe biden il
attend quoi de cette rencontre il est
parti chercher quoi concrètement
je suppose qu'il attend une aide si mu
et matérielles financières logistiques
qui pallie les inconvénients du départ
des troupes américaines puisque c'est
avec le pouvoir afghan depuis les nazis
de ce pays par les forces américaines et
celles de leurs alliés dépend très
largement de 2,2 de l'aide fournie aux
états unis aux différents pouvoirs qui
se sont succédé depuis 20 ans donc ce
qui ce qui est important pour lui c'est
qu'une période de transition soit
aménagé entre la situation actuelle et
la perspective d'un départ définitif des
troupes américaines et des autres c'est
à dire qu'ils qui sont encore dans ce
pays donc c'est quelque chose qui soit
plus paraît un petit peu dérisoire quoi
on ne rentre pas dans le situation et
l'impression d'une situation sans issue
aujourd'hui
alors on parle beaucoup en dézinguant
qui ont travaillé pour la coalition
internationale notamment pour la france
avec la possibilité qu'il soit désormais
pris pour cibles que faut-il faire
c'est une bonne question je suis pas sûr
d'avoir la réponse c'est à dire qu'à
partir du moment où les puissances
occidentales occupe militairement un
pays alors en avouant quand on lui
prêtait des imaginable mais plus
avouable comme les plus inavouables
d'ailleurs ça laisse toujours des traces
c'est à dire qu'on a suscité
effectivement la rall la collaboration
de locaux qui se retrouve complètement
abandonné lorsque les troupes étrangères
plie bagage il rentre à la maison et
c'est un scénario qu'on a déjà connu
dans d'autres pays et c'est chaque fois
le même drame
le pro
de fonds ne sera pas réglée tant que ces
puissances occidentales pour une fois
pour toutes
n'arrive pas la conclusion ferme et
définitif que essayer d'apporter aux
autres la démocratie le progrès les
droits de l'homme à coups de coûts de
l'intervention militaire de toute façon
ne mène qu'au fiasco pour ces puissances
d'interviews interventionniste et en
général un désastre pour les populations
concernées
et maintenant on sait qu'il ya eu des
pourparlers pour la paix en afghanistan
est ce que vous êtes optimiste pour la
suite il faut être mais on constate
quand même que ça fait quand même quand
on y réfléchit bien pratiquement 40 ans
où ce pays est en guerre finalement
d'une manière ou d'une autre depuis la
première intervention des moudjahidine
autres guinée qui à l'époque bénéficié
de l'aide financière et logistique des
etats-unis se souviennent l'action de
monsieur brésil ce qui à l'époque en
afghanistan jusqu'à la période actuelle
c'est une série ininterrompue
d'intervention étrangère
keane qui naquit non c'est en fait
qu'entretenir un climat de guerre de
belligérance dont on voit pas la fin
alors soyons optimistes au espérons un
jour ou l'autre les afghans eux-mêmes
finissent par comprendre que d'autres
solutions prologue comme se faire agréer
monogame merci à vous d'avoir été en
direct sur arte france je rappelle que
vous êtes analyste géopolitique merci